Here are the solutions. Great work if you got most of these right. For these
two parabolas, we know that they're going to open up or down, since they're in
the form y equals. We look at these numbers or the a value to determine whether
or not they open up, or whether or not they open down. Since the a value is
negative here, we know that this parabola must open down. And since the a value
is positive here, we know that this parabola opens up. To find the vertex of
this parabola, we simply look at the h and k value. h would be positive 4, by
setting this binomial equal to zero. And k would be positive 2. The number
added on the end. For this parabola, the vertex is 1,3. Again, we set the
binomial equal to zero. So that way, we get an x coordinate of x equals 1. The
y coordinate of the vertex is the k value, or just positive 3. These two
parabolas here open left or right, since they're of the form x equals. By
looking at the a value, we can see that one of them is negative, and the other
one is a positive 1. This means that the negative 1 must open to the left and
that the positive 1 must open to the right. Remember, negative a values for x
equals parabolas make the parabola open to the left, whereas positive values of
a for x equal parabolas make the parabola open to the right. And finally, to
find the vertex for this parabola, we look at the value of h here and the value
of k here. H is simply positive 2, our x coordinate of the vertex. And our y
coordinate of the vertex is positive 1. We set this binomial equal to 0, to get
y equals 1. And we find this vertex in a similar way. Here's the h value for
our vertex. The x coordinate is positive 2. And here's the y value for our
vertex, its negative 3. Remember we set the binomial y plus 3 equal to 0 and
solve for the y coordinate of this vertex.